now Trump leads the Republican field by
more than 30 points in second place
Florida Governor Rod DeSantis just
raised a whopping 8.2 million dollars 24
hours after his launch he's now
attacking former president Trump for
running to the left joining us now with
the reaction former Senator and
Ambassador Scott Brown along with
Democratic political strategist and
former senior advisor to President
Clinton Doug Shone uh gentlemen thank
you so much for joining us tonight on
Hannity uh Senator slash Ambassador I
want to start with you you know the
danger when you have a contested primary
is that they beat each other up so bad
that there's so much contention by the
time you get into the general election
the somebody who's so you know such a
big supporter of one won't go out and
support the other one and the Democrat
gets a skirt right through
yeah yeah it's uh the The Playbook we
see all the time it happened in the last
election cycle I mean there's plenty to
talk about uh between Trump and DeSantis
and all the other candidates I mean if I
guess if you were going after uh
president Trump uh you know listen I
support him I worked for the guy uh you
know I did some amazing things but when
you come to the covet issues and the
fact that he was basically responsible
for uh you know getting the vaccine in
place which some people think is great
some people don't and then he was
basically you know fauci was his
right-hand man so if DeSantis and others
are going to go after him you know go go
on facts you know this whole you know
Trump's now in the left what are you
kidding me no he's not I I think people
kind of tune that stuff out they want to
they want to figure out what are you
going to do for our country what are you
going to do about the Border what are
you going to do about fentanyl inflation
is two times higher than it was you know
when I got home from New Zealand same
same thing with gas you know you you
just can't make up a lack of standing
throughout the world right now the as
you referenced in your earlier segment
the apology tour it's enough and you're
right the Democrats you know they have
an RFK Junior problem uh and he is not
going anywhere and don't forget Joe
Biden's not even on the ballot in the
first in the nation primary state which
is New Hampshire and so RFK Jr is going
to be coming out of the gate with the
victory so uh when you have 82 percent
of the people in this country saying
it's going in the wrong direction the
Republicans need to figure it out you
know talk about the facts talk about the
issues and let's drive on
uh Doug yeah look you're a Democrat
um you've been a Democrat analyst but
you look as closely at the Republicans
is anybody what's your take what do you
make of the DeSantis Trump you know head
bashing right now I mean it started
early it's it started well before today
and it's gonna get even more fiery
well you know I I do agree with Scott
Brown I think for Ron DeSantis to try to
run to the right of Donald Trump given
his strength with conservative and very
conservative voters is a strategy that
is unlikely to succeed and indeed what
has happened in the last six months
Jason which we've all seen is Trump has
Consolidated his position and with the
attacks on him whether it be from
prosecutors to Media or even DeSantis
he's gotten stronger not weaker so I
think DeSantis especially with a very
bad launch which was full of glitches
and really did not maximize his position
I think he's got a difficult difficult
mountain to climb to take on Trump and
right now to me Trump's the odds on
favor
uh Senator how do you how do you see the
tangibles versus the intangibles you
know there's things that get caught up
in the polls but I got to tell you the
people who believe and support Donald
Trump you ain't moving them they they
they're not moving and Donald Trump is
so far out in front right now it feels
like he's lapping people
um how do you how do you assess that
what do you what do you say going into
you know the summer months here what can
you possibly do to break that down if
you're one of the competitors
well the beauty of it is is we are in
the first in the nation primary State
Republicans are participating I just had
Nikki Haley to my uh no Scott Brown no
BS Backyard Barbecue the other day we
had over 400 people in the rain people
looking in the windows and I had 16 of
the 18 presidential candidates and then
president Trump we had in a car
dealership with the 3 000 in a snowstorm
so they're coming out how do you get
through this I think it's early I mean I
was down 41 points when I ran for the
U.S Senate and won by eight or nine it's
early people are just kind of poking and
prodding yes president Trump has a rock
solid base of probably 32 to 34 percent
but there's others out there yeah
obviously Tim Scott Nikki Haley vice
president Pence you have obviously vivec
who just came on great ideas that
they're they're coming to New Hampshire
Nikki Haley was here and had six events
she's been here many many times whoever
comes here has to do with the New
Hampshire way it's the old story hey
what do you think about Mitt Romney oh I
think he's great I I met him he's he's
great he did a great job in
Massachusetts you're going to vote for
him well I I need to see him four or
five six more times first that's what
they need in New Hampshire so it goes it
starts here and people are gonna are
gonna weigh and measure all the things
that President Trump has been hammered
for obviously the we all know about it
and they're going to compare it to the
other people in the race and ultimately
as you referenced earlier if we don't
come together after the fact and we you
know we we we we sulk and we moan and
groan and we don't come get behind who
the ultimate nominee is we're going to
have a repeat of what just happened
uh Doug let's go back to that poll
66 of Americans are saying it would be
an unmitigated disaster if Joe Biden
were were re-elected he's not on the
ballot in the New Hampshire primary I
guess he's banking strongly on South
Carolina
um but you know his strategy is not
really paying off you have RFK junior or
20 plus percent of the vote now that's a
pretty big number for somebody who's
just gotten into the race
yeah
Jason I agree that the president has
very substantial vulnerabilities a
majority of Democrats don't want him to
run for reelection I think RFK Juniors a
threat to get anywhere from uh 25 to 30
percent of the primary vote that being
said I think it's important to note that
in the head-to-head races with Trump and
DeSantis Biden is either tied slightly
behind slightly ahead so to count Biden
out would be a profound mistake and as I
think you and Scott Brown rightly
pointed out the more the Republican
field fights and uh attacks one another
the better it is for Joe Biden
yeah it's going to be fascinating is it
play plays out uh we'll remind people
that uh next week
Sean Hannity is going to have a town
hall with uh coming up here with Donald
Trump it's going to be a fascinating one
to watch and then of course the debate
on Fox News that'll happen in August
Ambassador Senator Scott Brown Doug
Shone thank you so much hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else